merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation Philippe mouiller de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes sénateur les
républicains des Deux-Sèvres
vice-président de la commission des
affaires sociales et on commence
évidemment par la réforme des retraites
on l'a vu dans le journal les syndicats
qui se sont réunis hier devant
l'Assemblée nationale appelle la
multiplier les actions et les
initiatives d'ici mardi prochain journée
de grandes mobilisation ce que vous
redoutez une multiplication des grèves
et un éventuel blocage du pays alors on
est toujours inquiet parce que l'impact
économique peut-être importante et en
même temps il est logique que les
syndicats se mobilisent ils sont dans
leur rôle voilà je crois que ça fait
partie de l'expression à la fois de la
démocratie de la démocratie sociale
voilà donc le tout c'est d'avoir un
rapport de force qui existe mais qui
doit être aussi équilibré au regard des
enjeux nationaux est-ce que vous pensez
que le gouvernement va tenir face à la
rue et ne cèdera pas moi je pense que
oui mais parce qu'à la fois parce que je
pense qu'il n'a pas le choix et il s'est
engagé et donc le programme République
ces engageons personnellement dans cette
réforme et puis je crois que c'est une
réforme de responsabilité donc c'est un
cap politique important dans ce
quinquennat donc je vois pas le
gouvernement faire machine arrière il
peut peut-être moduler évoluer mais je
pense qu'il va être relativement ferme
au regard de ces engagements même si
dans ce type de réforme toujours être
prudent on a connu dont parle le passé
des évolutions on regarde des
mobilisations ouais mais ce qui peut se
contenter de moduler et de changer
finalement quelques points alors que il
y a eu quand même plus qu'un million de
personnes dans la rue jeudi dernier ça
faisait longtemps qu'on avait pas vu
autant de monde dans la rue est-ce que
ça donne pas l'impression de rester
sourd à ce que disent les Français je
crois que c'est c'est le jeu classique
on est sur une réforme qui est pas
définition est toujours un populaire
quel que soit les gouvernants lorsqu'on
a touché lorsqu'on a évoqué le débat des
retrait c'était un format un peu plus
d'air les gens ont été mobilisent dans
la rue mais d'ailleurs moi j'ai croisé
un certain nombre de de de syndicalistes
j'ai rosé ascendant de personnes qui ont
été mobilisées c'est à la folie retraite
mais aussi d'autres messages qui ont été
portés d'inquiétude de de d'angoisse
vis-à-vis de la situation donc on voit
bien comment on dit c'est un moyen
d'exprimer une situation du moment qui
est alimentée certes par les retraites
peut être plus générale et je crois
qu'il faut entendre mais également les
messages ça veut dire que vous craignez
que ça prenne de l'ampleur que ça se
transforme en autre chose qu'une
rencontre
mais en même temps je pense que pour
l'instant on est vraiment dans un
rapport de force on va dire entre
guillemets classique logique et donc
maintenant place le débat parlementaire
et justement on va parler du fond de
cette réforme puisque hier vous avez
auditionné avec vos collègues sénateurs
de la commission des affaires sociales
le ministre du Travail Olivier du soft
et le haut le président du Haut Conseil
des finances publiques Pierre Moscovici
deux auditions dont on va parler avec
Audrey pietas
[Musique]
bonjour et Audrey les sénateurs
auditionnés donc hier Olivier du socle
ministre du Travail dans le cadre de
cette réforme des retraites oui avec des
échanges très techniques et des
précisions qui vont permettre ensuite au
sénateur de préparer leurs amendements
sur le texte sur le papier ce n'était
donc pas une séquence politique il
faudra attendre les débats en séance il
n'empêche certains sénateurs en ont
profité pour glisser des petits
commentaires comme la sénatrice de
gauche Corinne Ferret qui a décrit avant
de poser ces questions une réforme je
cite injuste brutale et inutile il y a
eu aussi des questions sur la forme du
texte ça peut paraître anecdotique mais
c'est important pour la suite cette
réforme des retraites elle est proposée
par la voix faut s'accrocher un peu d'un
projet de loi de finance rectificatif de
la sécurité sociale c'est un texte
budgétaire ce n'est pas un texte
traditionnel et ça permet au
gouvernement d'utiliser le 49-3 à
volonté si je puis dire et de garder une
cartouche pour un autre projet de loi
parce que l'utilisation du 49-3 elle est
limitée et sur les textes budgétaires on
peut l'utiliser à plusieurs reprises la
limite aussi le temps des débats
parlementaires c'est important c'est une
manœuvre politique et ça la sénatrice
socialisme Monique Lubin la repérer
on sent la tension dans la question de
Monique Lubin monsieur mouillé vous êtes
d'accord avec elle il aura fallu un vrai
texte sur ce sujet oui moi j'ai le pense
également parce que au-delà de l'aspect
technique qui est proposée par le
gouvernement on voit bien que lorsqu'on
est sur un texte budgétaire alors le
pouvoir d'amendement est limité on ne
peut ne modifier les choses que on
regarde le chiffre et de Somme et non
pas sur le fond ou sur des précisions et
je crois que en matière de pédagogie
lorsqu'on veut porter de réforme qui
semble quand même un populaire sur le
papier il y a des contreparties il y a
des points positifs dans cette réforme
et quelque part on parle très vite de
ces points positifs parce que on parle
avant tout et bien d'âge de somme alors
que on a une vraie étape plus-value et
je crois qu'avec un texte dédié et bien
on aurait pu débattre on aurait pu
rentrer dans le détail pour montrer à un
certain nombre de Français la plus-value
les plus-values les avantages de cette
réforme et alors que là on parle
principalement que des inconvénients oui
parce que les mesures d'accompagnement
dont on parle beaucoup passeront elle
par décret exactement et donc c'est
toute la limite du système d'ailleurs
un élément qu'on a retrouvé lors du lors
de l'audition c'était beaucoup de
regrets parce qu'on avait aussi des
questions sur les poissons de réversion
sur les carrières longues sur la
situation des femmes des questions qui
décidons d'ailleurs des avancées et donc
on veut te porter de la Saint-Omer de
d'avancer au Sénat mais forcément le
texte budgétaire va nous limiter et on
sera plus dans les commentaires que dans
la traduction donc là il y a un vrai
sujet sur la méthode vous expliquer
alors ce choix parce que finalement ça
c'est ça va être défavorable pour le
gouvernement aussi alors ça complexifie
le débat alors c'est plus simple pour
eux techniquement parce qu'ils vont
pouvoir comme ça limiter le temps de
parole on l'a évoqué notamment
l'Assemblée nationale ils vont
éventuellement avoir la possibilité
d'utiliser dans le cadre de 3 donc on
voit bien que techniquement c'est plus
simple pour eux ça encadre le système
mais en matière de débat et bien on voit
bien que c'est aussi limitatif donc la
seule moyenne de contreca tout ça c'est
une véritable pédagogie et donc ce qu'on
a senti hier c'est d'orientation
technique une vision du Gouvernement sur
ce projet mais il faut quand même
beaucoup de pédagogie c'est vrai pour
les parlementaires alors imaginez pour
le grand public et un problème de
méthode dans la manière dont le
gouvernement a géré cette réforme des
retraites oui je pense parce que je fais
partie de ceux qui pensent qu'on aurait
dû à mettre en place un centre de
préalable l'exemple type c'est notamment
tout le débat qui concerne les poissons
de réversion c'est un sujet important
fondamental moi je suis porteur avec mon
groupe du principe du poisson dévation
pour les parents qui décèdent lorsqu'on
a un enfant handicapé mais techniquement
comment ça se passe et bien on le sait
pas pour l'instant on a aussi le débat
autour de l'employabilité des seniors
moi j'aurais préféré qu'il y a un texte
spécifique préalable qui emmène ensuite
le débat sur les retrait donc on voit
bien que on met tout en même temps on
met tous les sujets sur la table mais en
plus en matière de débat parlementaire
on va être limité à un débat budgétaire
on va parler de l'emploi des seniors
puisque effectivement ça fait partie des
questions et Audrey lors de son audition
et Olivier dussop a annoncé un nouveau
projet de loi en faveur de l'emploi
parce que c'est un sujet qui a été
relevé par de nombreux sénateurs qui qui
aussi dans le débat public quand on
regarde le taux d'emploi des 55 62 ans
pour l'instant seul la moitié est encore
en emploi un quart est au chômage un
carré taux RSA alors le ministre a fait
des annonces
vous avez ensuite souhaité savoir si
pour un certain nombre de mesures
notamment sur l'emploi des seniors les
questions relatives à la formation les
concernant un texte législatif haute que
ce bel effet s rectificatif était prévu
je vous le confirme et d'ici l'été nous
aurons l'occasion de proposer au
Parlement l'examen d'un autre texte sur
l'emploi elle travaille et qui aura
aussi vocation apporté un centre de
mesure dans le cadre de la mise en
oeuvre de France travail de
l'accompagnement amélioré renforcé des
allocataires du RSA ou encore pour
donner suite aux propositions qui ont
été faites dans le cadre des discussions
entre partenaires sociaux sur la
formation professionnelle alors ça
arrive peut-être un peu dans le désordre
mais il y aura un texte est-ce que ça
vous aura rassure alors ça me rassure
mais comme on l'a évoqué j'aurais
préféré qu'on débattre d'abord de ce
sujet là parce que ça apportait en plus
des arguments favorables alors
qu'aujourd'hui on juste pondu une
attention voilà je crois de nouveau on
voit bien que les choses sont pas pris
forcément dans le bon ordre c'est un
point essentiel bah j'ai dès lors que on
considère qu'il faut travailler plus
longtemps on a la situation aujourd'hui
de l'emploi des seniors qui n'est pas
très favorable donc si on règle pas ce
problème là si on a pas une véritable
avancée une possibilité d'améliorer le
système c'est une partie une pierre
angulaire de la réforme qui tombe voilà
donc on aurait dû préalablement traiter
de ce sujet là avant donc lecher c'est
très forme mécanique et en tous les cas
budgétaire c'est
ce qu'avait propose des seniors est-ce
que vous regrettez que le gouvernement
ne vous ai pas suivi est-ce que pour
vous ça aurait permis d'amoindrir un peu
la contestation oui je le pense je pense
que on voit bien aujourd'hui les grands
sujets qui sont portés dans la rue et
pas les syndicats et je pense une grande
partie de ces sujets là on aurait pu les
traiter préalablement qui aurait été une
condition à mon avis pour en tout cas
rassurer ou en tout cas peut-être donner
une image plus favorable à cette réforme
qui par définition reste une réforme
difficile comme je l'évoquais tout à
l'heure alors sur l'emploi des seniors
les entreprises de plus de 300 employés
devront publier un index il pourra y
avoir des sanctions le ministre a dit
que ça viendrait les détails viendrait
par la suite est-ce que vous allez
est-ce que vous pourrez proposer des
amendements ce sens oui complètement
parce que il y a une règle de confiance
dès lors que on considère que cette
réforme des retraites et bien n'est pas
financé par un effort supplémentaire des
entreprises et j'y suis favorable pour
la compétitivité des entreprises il faut
une contrepartie et la contrepartie
c'est notamment l'employabilité des
seniors donc ça veut dire que avec les
partenaires sociaux il faut avec les
partenaires sociaux c'est fondamentales
il faut bien mettre en place un certain
nombre d'outils à la fois des outils de
motivation d'accompagnement des
personnes on m'a parlé de la formation
mais également des contraintes parce que
c'est un contrat de n'ordonnant et c'est
essentiel sur une peut-être une dernière
question sur l'allongement de l'âge
légal de départ en retraite le ministre
a rappelé à plusieurs reprises hier que
le Sénat avait voté depuis quatre ans
pour cet allongement c'est peut-être une
manière de vous inciter à voter cette
réforme est-ce que vous la votez sur le
papier en l'état maintenant
le principe oui puisque comme vous
l'avez évoqué ça fait quatre ans que
l'on vote une réforme en tout cas quand
nous avons un amendement on peut les
fesses pour montrer vers quoi nous
voulons aller en matière de réforme des
retraites donc on va être cohérent
logiquement mais on a besoin quand même
d'avoir des précisions sur un certain
nombre de sujets qui ne sont pas
aujourd'hui dans le texte qui sont
renvoyés et ça ça fait partie des points
essentiels on voit bien à un moment
donné que sur des on va parler tout à
l'heure dans avantages de l'emploi des
femmes de la situation c'est un point
fondamental qu'est-ce qu'on fait
vis-à-vis des enfants qu'est-ce qu'on
fait par rapport à la portentalité
qu'est-ce qu'on fait vis-à-vis des
aidants enfin les questions sont
nombreuses et nous pourrons pas
simplement et bien voter un texte
regarde élément chiffrés technique il
nous faudra tout le parallèle pour
pouvoir appréhender vraiment les enjeux
et ça ça fait partie aussi de notre
méthode de travail au Sénat mais même
sur le calendrier alors sur les 64 ans
vous l'avez dit vous l'avez voté donc la
rapidité aussi également mais est-ce que
vous allez garder ce même calendrier à
savoir une application en 2030 et où
est-ce que vous allez aussi décaler le
l'entrée en vigueur finalement de ce
calendrier parce que là ça touche des
personnes qui sont très proches de la
retraite et qui avaient peut-être déjà
des projets de vie tout à fait ça fait
partie des deux questions que nous avons
en ce moment sur la table que nous
travaillons à la fois la Commission va
se cale et à la commission des finances
pour l'instant je suis encore prudent
parce que les travaux n'ont pas
complètement débuté mais vous avez
relevé les deux pointes de difficulté
c'est-à-dire qu'on considère que la mise
en pratique est beaucoup trop rapide et
donc même chose c'est-à-dire qu'on a un
lien de confiance avec les personnes qui
ont des projets de vie là pour la fin de
l'année pour l'année prochaine et puis
en même temps considère que certainement
que la mise en service est beaucoup trop
rapide il faut aller les supplémentaires
voilà donc c'est parti aussi des
éléments de discussion mais vous avez
enfin ça transpire déjà vous l'avez
évoqué on a quand même quelques points
de cadrage mais qui reste quand même sur
une ligne de conduite ou on suit plutôt
les propositions du gouvernement qui
sont en grande partie d'ailleurs les
propositions de Sénat il y a une autre
audition on en a parlé que vous avez
fait hier c'est celle de Pierre
Moscovici qui est le président du Haut
Conseil des finances publiques alors lui
il dit que il vous a dit que l'impact
financier de la réforme était faible en
2023 voir que ça allait coûter
d'ailleurs on finance publique et ils
regrette d'ailleurs de ne pas pouvoir
mesurer les effets sur les finances
publiques à moyen et à long terme vous
êtes d'accord avec lui oui tout à fait
alors il regrette finalement de pas
avoir de vision publique il y a pas que
le sujet des retraites depuis de
nombreux mois que ce soit avec ces
différentes casquettes notamment pour
moi de la Cour des comptes il évoque la
nécessité d'avoir une vision stratégique
d'engagement d'investissement des
politiques publiques et donc ça concerne
tous les domaines et je crois qu'on peut
que partager on a besoin de transparence
on a besoin de vision pour pouvoir
piloter nos politiques publiques pour
les retraites c'est nécessaire alors
hier il était dans un rôle qui était
limité puisqu'on lui demandait
simplement de par d'ailleurs sa fonction
d'analyser la situation de 2023 du texte
qui nous est proposé donc forcément il a
fait une analyse j'irai contamiste et
donc avec très peu de conclusions donc
on était un peu frustré mais les points
essentiels pour nous ça va être cette
fois ça casquette Cour des comptes ou la
réellement sur les trajectoires
budgétaires sur les 20 30 ans qui
viennent quelle est la situation et
quelles évolutions sont proposées mais
on voit bien que l'enjeu des retraites
rentre dans un enjeu global de
situations des finances publiques qui ne
sont pas bonnes aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a cette réforme fondamentale
mais quid en matière de dépenses quid en
matière de politique également en
matière d'économie et si on n'a pas une
vision globale c'est qu'un élément
certes important pour les Français mais
c'est qu'un élément notre situation
budgétaire globale peut-être un point
justement sur cette audition de Monsieur
moscovicii il a souligné le fait que le
gouvernement se basait peut-être sur des
prévisions trop optimistes avec un taux
de chômage très bas autour de 4,5% mais
finalement ça peut peut-être changer par
la suite qu'est-ce que vous en pensez je
crois que depuis le début ce
gouvernement d'ailleurs on l'a dénoncé
au moment du pfss et aux membres du PLF
ce gouvernement s'appuie sur des taux de
croissance sur des taux également
budgétaires qui sont pour nous décorer
de la réalité on voit bien que il y a
une forme d'optimiste qui arrange parce
que ça arrange les comptes d'une façon
générale donc il a réitéré cette
critique il faudrait être prudent mais
ça veut dire que ces critique là était
aussi un point essentiel lorsqu'on parle
d'équilibre budgétaire des comptes
lorsqu'on parle l'équipe budgétaire
notamment de des retraites ça veut dire
que si taux de chômage n'est pas
satisfaisant si taux de croissance n'est
pas aussi fort et bien c'est une
dégradation des comptes donc ça amplifie
même d'ailleurs le besoin de réformer le
système le régime justement un dernier
mot puisque vous parlez du taux de
chômage hier ont été publiés les
chiffres du chômage le nombre de
chômeurs a baissé au 4e type moyen de
3,6% par rapport au trimestre précédent
le nombre de demandeurs d'emploi
retrouve son plus bas niveau depuis le
3e trimestre 2011 est-ce qu'Emmanuel
Macron sera le président du plein emploi
alors en tous les cas il est le présent
des circonstances et de la situation
c'est-à-dire que le contexte économique
fait que d'une façon générale il y a une
demande forte et d'ailleurs à des sujets
pour nous enfin pour moi qui soit élu de
l'Ouest c'est comment les entreprises
arrivent à trouver aujourd'hui des
salariés pour venir les accompagner
parce qu'on a un vrai problème
d'employabilité voilà donc on a à la
fois j'irai un contexte économique
national international qui est favorable
quand même un certain nombre de
difficultés il faut quand même conscient
que le poids d'adepte que l'évolution
des taux d'intérêt on a quand même
indicateurs qui sont inquiétants voilà
donc il est plutôt dans une logique où
ils surf sur une situation qui est
plutôt favorable mais avec et quand même
quelques réformes notamment concernant
l'allègement et cet Harmonia encore avec
le débat sur leur retraite mais c'est
clair pour nous que l'allègement des
charges sur les entreprises contribue
aussi une meilleure compétitivité merci
Audrey merci vous êtes en train de
parler de Olivier du sable dans le cas
Olivier du socle et puis Gabriel Attal
voilà
on parlera évidemment réforme des
retraites tout à l'heure Audrey on va
continuer à parler emploi et chômage on
va aller du côté de Poitiers retrouver
Delphine Blanchard bonjour Delphine
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous Delphine
vous êtes journaliste à La Nouvelle
République et Delphine vous allez nous
parler de territoire zéro chômeurs les
signatures des conventions 36 premiers
contrastes signés à Poitiers
c'est ça le dispositif c'est concrétisé
à Poitiers la semaine dernière 36
premiers contrats de travail c'est donc
un retour à l'emploi pour des personnes
qui en étaient jusqu'ici totalement
exclus l'objectif final à Poitiers c'est
un retour à l'emploi de 340 dont deux
entreprises à but de d'emploi les
premières recrues elles sont issues de
quartier de Poitiers plutôt défavorisés
comme Patricia habitants de Bel-Air qui
suit le dispositif depuis 2015 tout a
commencé pour elle avec la découverte du
dispositif à Mauléon dans les
Deux-Sèvres que votre invité doit bien
connaître Oriane c'est l'une des toutes
premières communes à avoir lancé le
dispositif en 2017 en France
Patricia et travailleuse handicapés
depuis 10 ans elle était au chômage
après avoir enchaîné des CDD des petits
boulots précaires elle a donc démarré le
tout premier CDI de sa vie à 58 ans ce
qui fait la force de ce dispositif c'est
que c'est un contrat adapté à chaque
situation une personne qui a des enfants
qu'elle doit à l'école entre 8h et 9h et
c'est le début de journée au travail qui
est aménagé et décalé pour elle c'est
vraiment du cas par cas il y a aussi
Stéphane qui a signé le premier CDI de
sa vie à 56 ans et dans sa nouvelle
Ville travaille les jeudis et vendredis
dans une épicerie solidaire certains
vont faire du maraîchage d'autres encore
de l'aide à la personne s'il y a un CDI
ça signifie toute une vie qui se
transforme un salaire régulier les
galères financières qui s'envolent de la
légèreté nouvelle vie pleine de
promesses dans la Vienne Poitiers n'est
pas la première ville à rejoindre ce
dispositif il y avait eu Châtellerault
en mars 2022 une chose en tout cas est
certaine personne n'est in employable
mais j'ai une question pour vous
monsieur le sénateur à votre avis alors
que Oriane l'a dit le taux de chômage en
France est en net baisse de 3,6%.
pensez-vous que ce genre de dispositif
soit toujours aussi
utile car s'il remet le cercle pied à
l'étrier il est aussi très coûteux pour
l'État ses emplois sont en effet
subventionnés à hauteur des 18000 euros
par an et par poste
alors oui je pense que ce dispositif est
essentiel et d'autant plus lorsque le
taux de chômage est bas parce que ça
veut dire que les personnes qui ne sont
pas en plus aujourd'hui sont souvent
très éloignées et donc il faut un effort
particulier pour pouvoir faire en sorte
qu'il revienne dans un système
généralisé d'emploi et concernant le
coût financier vous qui est important
vous l'avez évoqué mais en même temps il
faut le remettre en parallèle d'une
situation où on paierait certain nombre
d'allocations d'aide sociale pour des
personnes qui ne seraient pas employées
et lorsqu'on fait le parallèle entre les
deux on se rend compte que globalement
il vaut mieux utiliser l'argent public
pour faire en sorte que des gens
retrouvent une situation sociale ce ne
se i de contrat a duré indéterminer et
fondamental vous l'avez évoqué et je
crois que globalement tout le monde est
gagnant parce que l'État reprend un
certain nombre de personnes les
accompagnent dans l'emploi avec certains
coûts financiers mais qu'elle aurait eu
en grande partie et les personnes
retrouvent une situation idéale voilà et
donc je crois que ces structures
d'insertion que ce soit le les
entreprises et puis d'emploi ou
globalement les structures d'insertion
sont encore plus nécessaires dans les
territoires autour de chômage est bas
parce que comme je l'ai dit il y a un
accompagnement particulier et vous
l'avez très bien dit personne n'est in
employable
Delphine vous avez vu votre réponse je
crois on regarde le truc
on regarde votre une vous ne l'expliquez
votre voiture d'occasion le modèle d'un
grand
oui un grand c'est près de Châtellerault
c'est un fleuron de l'industrie dans la
Vienne et Édouard Philippe hier est venu
battre le rappel de la campagne dans
cette industrie là et donc on a mis en
avant ce sujet effectivement à
Châtellerault qui a perdu beaucoup
d'emplois et ces dernières années avec
les Fonderies du Poitou mais il reste
quand même les voitures d'occasion merci
beaucoup Delphine d'avoir été avec nous
on a vu votre une et on vous retrouve
évidemment très vite dans cette émission
merci Delphine Blanchard depuis Poitiers
on va revenir à l'actualité du Sénat on
va parler du handicap puisque évidemment
c'est un sujet que vous traitez beaucoup
ici au Sénat Philippe mouillé vous êtes
depuis hier le président du groupe
d'études handicap quels seront vos
priorités
quel est l'objectif de ce groupe alors
d'abord
appréhendule rappeler que c'est un
engagement du plan du Sénat qui leur des
universités d'été du Conseil national
consultatif des personnes handicapées
cette CPH a annoncé cette volonté de
mobiliser le Sénat sur ses grands enjeux
alors trois objectifs principaux d'abord
une veille juridique euh regarde la
situation des politiques de handicap en
France avec le recueil un certain nombre
de sollicitations ou d'association de
structure et puis ensuite vous avez un
travail de fond concernant notamment
l'ensemble des textes qui seront votés
au Sénat puisque l'idée c'est d'avoir un
référent handicap dans chacune des
commissions permanent du Sénat troisième
objectif c'est de faire en sorte que le
Sénat lui-même et bien soit tourné soit
j'irai en performance vis-à-vis du
handicap que ce soit en matière d'emploi
des travailleurs handicapés
d'accessibilité et notamment
d'accessibilité numérique qui est un
enjeu fondamental notamment pour tout à
chacun et d'accessibilité tout court on
imagine que c'est pas facile évidemment
le Sénat c'est un monument historique
c'est là aussi vous allez avoir des
choses qui vont être faites des travaux
même si le ciel a déjà avancé sera
Sanson le sujet voilà donc on a vraiment
cette disons globale et puis très
heureux d'avoir 62 sénateurs qui se sont
engagés dans ce groupe de travail
évidemment on suivra vos travaux on
termine par les républicains votre
partie il y avait les vœux cette semaine
d'Éric Ciotti c'était mardi et alors on
a remarqué sur la photo de famille c'est
toujours les absents qui se font marquer
vous savez c'est Aurélien Pradier
regardez cette image j'aurais bien
Pradier qui n'était pas là aux côtés de
Bruno Retailleau et d'érections dit que
le moment est à l'unité c'est un peu
plus
je ne connais pas le l'agenda de donc je
ne peux pas vous dire exactement où il
était ce soir-là aujourd'hui clairement
il a été positionné comme vice-président
avec François Xavier Bellamy de notre
partie c'est un signe Clark de la part
de vouloir rassembler l'ensemble des
acteurs vous ne retaillons à ses côtés
voilà le geste est là après l'attitude
de relais imprégner et bien ça le
regarde on verra bien les évolutions
c'est vraiment que c'est une question
d'agenda parce qu'on a l'impression
qu'aurait rien Pradier il essaye de se
démarquer sur la réforme des retraites
il a une position qui est différente de
celle du parti est-ce que quand on a la
place qui l'occupe dans l'organigramme
c'est à dire qu'il est vice-président
avec François-Xavier Bellamy ce qui est
quand même le plus haut niveau en
dessous d'Éric soutien est-ce qu'on peut
avoir ce genre d'attitude alors de
nouveau je suis prudent vis-à-vis de son
absence à cette réunion mais d'une façon
générale je crois que s'il veut et bien
faire peser ses idées s'il veut pouvoir
revendiquer une ligne différente et bien
il faut être autour de la table la
meilleure façon de débattre et de porter
un message c'est d'être présent voilà
donc on verra pour la suite des
événements
aujourd'hui il est très mobilisé à
l'Assemblée nationale avec son groupe de
parlementaire si je crois que s'il veut
perdurer dans notre famille politique et
il est nécessaire qu'il soit autour de
la table pour pouvoir débattre merci
Philippe mouillé on va parler de ces
sujets dans quelques secondes d'abord je
vous précise que dans 20 minutes dans le
club d'État on parlera de la réforme des
retraites opération pédagogique et
conviction pour le gouvernement nous
avons suivi le ministre Gabriel Attal
dans une réunion publique dans une
commune rurale de l'Aube vous verrez ce
reportage dans 20 minutes on va reparler
des républicains de la réforme des
retraites tout de suite c'est votre
président de groupe qui nous rejoindre
une Retailleau